merci beaucoup aux karine pour ces
précisions la tempête xynthia aussi
frappé fort la nuit dernière en
charente-maritime causant la mort de
plusieurs personnes et d'importants
dégâts
la rochelle a été particulièrement
touchée sur place anne billets paix à
l'inde arrivant ils n'ont que leurs bras
pour évacuer cette femme âgée après la
tempête tout le quartier et inondées et
les pompiers sont débordés alors on
s'aide entre voisins battre ce soir
monsieur qu'on fait hors de l'eau en
show vient après moi je suis retourné
chez moi sans verrons ce qu'il faut à
quelques kilomètres on emploie les
grands moyens pour évacuer les campings
les résidentes été surpris en plein
sommeil par la montée des eaux
car au milieu de la nuit la mer
déchaînée est passé par dessus les
digues et malgré le danger certains
promeneurs prennent tous les risques
le port de la rochelle disparaît sous
les flots
les bateaux se retrouve au dessus des
voitures et les piétons dans l'eau en
fête est très dangereuse qu'on a surtout
peur des bouches d'égout rhin s'est pas
trop en marche
robin s'est passé inquiétant jamais vu
d'aussi haute n'a jamais bu l'eau
atteint ce niveau là et pourtant là
aussi des automobilistes s'aventure dans
le haut malgré les conseils de prudence
ils sont rapidement prises au piège
certains parviennent à se dégager
d'autres tentent en vain de récupérer
leur véhicule
à
rester ici pour l'instant voilà ça peu
la panique la sur le port nous ont
rentré de mission et on nous a requis
pour des personnes qui étaient bloquées
dans un véhicule ouais donc c'est un peu
pour monter déborder la à la lumière du
jour on constate les dégâts parfois
considérables cet hôtel a tout perdu
on avait donc des vagues de plus d'un
mètre cinquante donc sur la route
donc c'est énorme donc cette détruites
il a tout détruit tout tous les effets
personnels ont fait le tour en fin de
compte de l'hôtel ils sont revenus par
une autre entrée donc c'est vraiment
apocalyptique en charente maritime
six personnes ont péri dans la tempête
et deux autres sont portées disparues
un bilan peut-être encore provisoire
nous allons rejoindre